we're joined now by former senior
adviser to president
obama valerie jarrett she's attended two
presidential inaugurations valerie good
morning thanks for being with us
thank you good morning to you all this
is certainly going to be a very
different inauguration given
covet and the conser security
precautions do you have any concerns
about safety at the capitol for the
inauguration
i had the opportunity anthony to work
with the secret service
for all eight years of president obama
and vice president biden's term
and there are no more professional
competent men and women that i know so
i'm confident that they'll do everything
possible to keep
keep people safe conspicuously
conspicuously absent at this
inauguration
will be the outgoing president it's the
first time an outgoing president has
skipped an inauguration in 152 years
what sort of message do you think that
sends to the world
well anthony uh there's been nothing
conventional about this president since
day one and so i don't think it should
come as any surprise
to anyone that he would also not
continue with the tradition
of showing this smooth transition of
power as you know he didn't cooperate
early on with the transition he has yet
to acknowledge uh that joe biden will be
the next president
and so it's really no surprise and i
think what's refreshing though
is that in one day we will have new
leadership in america
and that's the reason for the rest of
the world particularly our allies around
the world
to be um overjoyed valerie how important
though do you think are those traditions
i remember very vividly when michelle
and barack obama stood outside the white
house and welcomed the trumps and listen
there doesn't seem to be any love lost
between those two families at the time
because donald trump had said some very
nasty things about
barack obama michelle obama wrote in her
book about how she felt that you know
her family was in danger because of
because of donald trump but yet they
welcomed them welcomed them very
graciously to the white house at that
time
how important are these traditions for
americans to see that we
are that it it can be peaceful and
should be peaceful
yeah it's a good question gail i was
actually there that day and it was
excruciatingly painful i remember as the
obama said goodbye to the house staff
people who had
taken such good care of them over the
years many of them
older and black who had lived to see a
black president and
first lady in the relationships there
and i saw how
incredibly gracious president and mrs
obama
were to the trumps and you're right they
weren't at all happy about the occasion
but they rose to the occasion
and that's what you're supposed to do we
lead by example here in this country
and so those traditions are very
important they symbolize the strength of
our democracy
but we will move on and i think
beginning
midday tomorrow you'll see a whole new
tone from our new president and vice
president
where do you stand on the question of to
impeach or not to impeach you know there
are some people that are saying
goodbye good riddance let the healing
begin let's all move on and others say
no no no not so fast there should be
people should be held accountable and by
people i mean donald trump
and in order to have healing you have to
have accountability
at the same time the biden
administration is coming on with a whole
bunch of ugly on their plate
where do you stand on this question well
what's
uh good about the biden administration
is its ability to multitask and i think
what
uh president-elect biden has said is
he's going to focus on the american
people
tackling the covid rebuilding our
economy reversing many of the
deletorious actions that president trump
took including the muslim ban
giving certainty to the dreamers
rejoining the climate
accord rejoining the world health
organization putting science back in
our efforts and so he will move forward
on that effort and then i think it's up
to the senate to decide
uh when they move forward with this
trial and i think it's not just about
holding president trump accountable
uh for inciting a riot in an attempt to
overthrow
our government and the smooth transition
of power but it's also a message to
everyone who follows in his footsteps
about what is acceptable behavior and
what is not
at the same time valerie can be it can
be a very disruptive and very divisive
event
at the beginning of an administration
which is trying to get off on a strong
foot and deal with
with a an escalating covet crisis so
there's a delicate balance there now
right
well of course there is a delicate
balance and i think it's going to be up
to the leadership in the senate to make
sure for example
anthony that president biden's cabinet
has
confirmed that needs to happen swiftly
given the magnitude of the challenges
that we're facing
and at the same time as they're
conducting a trial they will have to do
two things at once and
it is a very challenging time but the
house has already moved forward with its
impeachment and so it will be up to the
senate to have a trial
and i they would hopefully do it as
expeditiously but as thoroughly and as
transparently as possible
because the american people will be
watching the american people the world
is going to be watching as you know and
history is going to be made the world la
harris and
chief justice uh sonia sotomayera who's
going to be giving her the oath
judge uh justice sotomayor is going to
be holding the bible when kamala harris
takes the oath
that's going to be quite a sight to see
yes it will gail
i have goosebumps just when you mention
it the first woman the first person of
color
as a vice president oh my gosh tune in
everybody
yes thank you valerie jarrett we will
see you tomorrow